i was actually in la for i don't i
haven't made a movie here in many many
many years but i happened to be here
last
march was it maybe something like that
march march
and my agent who is now nick's agent as
well
uh
gave me the script when i was getting on
the plane terrific script i got off the
plane called him immediately and said
what's the story of this and
he gave me the background on
nick and
i said what else has he done well
he's made a documentary
and uh
oh
hmm
and
but the script was so good i mean really
just first rate and he should be getting
looked all the credit is you're all
filmmakers so you know this it started
with the script and it's just really an
extraordinary script
the film is is i think is terrific but
it's because that script is so good and
he'd spent such a
hard and and creative time thinking
rethinking before it got to me
so uh
that was extraordinary work that he put
into it so i said look let's get
together anyhow and just talk so we came
up to uh to our uh in and and restaurant
and
andrew finkelstein uh who's now my agent
and brian young my manager had been
talking for a while and andrew had read
this script and really liked it but you
know we couldn't get the money and uh
we're running around trying to get it
and um so he would call to check in
every now and then and say come on you
ready what's going on get the money
what's let's make a movie so finally i
called him up after i
got it i said okay i got it and he said
okay stand by and i guess that's when he
transmitted the script to richard and 18
hours later he called back he said okay
he read it he digs it he wants to meet
you go meet him at his hotel i said
great where's he staying mercer and he
said no no he owns a hotel he runs
what are you talking about and so i
didn't know he had this double life as a
hotel proprietor uh so
um
uh
and
i go up to the bedford post then uh a
member of relay chateau and um it's uh
it's this wonderful place
and there richard's right super punctual
always and he's right on time and we
meet in the restaurant there's about you
know 50 other diners there we sit down
and he says okay i got it you know great
script but first time director it's a
little scary let's talk about uh how
we're gonna do you know how you see this
and so we talked for a while and we got
comfortable
and uh we started talking more and we
had this three hour meeting
and so at the end it was getting a
little loose and he said you know so
well nick what do you what do you have
something you want to work on here you
know that you think i said well you know
the scenes with the girlfriend you know
maybe there's another he said yeah that
on the page that can always be a little
tough um i had some ideas anyway i
thought maybe i'd be a little more
aggressive you know what come here stand
up and say let's do it and so we start
and i'm always game so i'm like okay so
i'm now i'm playing the mistress roll
i'm reading the lines he's ready to lie
and i'm you know he was born to play
that role i want you to be born for it
thank you
um i feel very flattered as i did in the
restaurant and uh so i'm screaming
you're never leaving your wife you're
just using me and he's you know no i
come here you're going to be with me and
it's
and he throws me up against the wall the
restaurant in full view of the 50 diners
and he says uh he looks deeply into my
eyes with the richard gere seductive
look and i stared back and i said
i would kiss you right now
and then he stared back at me like i was
crazy and then uh
and then he laughed and he said well
maybe we'll try it the way any actor
works and certainly the way i work is is
that you've got to um
i mean certainly you have to fulfill the
requirements of what what a character
does so in this case i didn't know much
about trading or any of that stuff so
um
it's nick's world so he he brought me
into that world
and he used my time very well so i
really met people in situations that
were
really feeding what what i needed to
know
to play the part and and to to
to do it smoothly enough that that there
weren't fingers pointing at it you know
if someone knows something well it's
very fluid
uh it's second nature so i wanted to
have that kind of ease with that process
a lot of it was hanging out in offices
it was just
sometimes it was talking to people who
are in this world and in many different
levels of this world
um went to the stock exchange we went to
the stock exchange yeah there was there
was a one the one
that whole experience was kind of kind
of wonderful but there was one one guy
that uh
it was a key kind of to the energy of it
and he's an 80 year old guy that's
working at at the stock exchange
he had this amazing youthful energy and
i started talking to him about
he said he'd been working there since he
was 17
and he couldn't imagine having another
job he said it was just
play every day
this adrenaline rush of just playing and
being on the edge of these
these deals making the deal look frankly
i see the character much more like
clinton than i do like madoff that's
shakespearean stuff to me it's that
failed hero that what is wrong
you know clinton is shakespearean to me
what was wrong that
he had a moment where he could have
done such extraordinary things
and there was that flaw uh
these these characters of great talent
and great
potential uh
the flaws make them even more
interesting
uh everyone in new york has a vision
some some plan that they're they're
working on so really the city itself is
peripheral and that's the way this was
shot and it was maybe the first movie
that i really noticed looked like new
york now like a woody allen movie like
manhattan very different because he's
looking at it
and he's telling you he's looking at it
all the time and beautiful for that yeah
but this feels like someone who's
actually living in new york